it's Mother's Day tomorrow so it seemed
like a good reason as any to finally
talk about this this is a topic I have
been meaning to talk about for about as
long as I've been doing the animation
junkie sub series and I just never got
around it I kind of wish I had sooner
because it's I'm not sure it's as
relevant as it was my thought was first
thing I'm talking about it because
Disney seems to have kind of broken this
streak a little bit with their more
recent films or at least some of them
but it has been observed for a fairly
decent chunk of time now that there are
not a heck of a lot of mothers in Disney
movies for the main characters I'm
talking about a lot of well frequently
dead or had the very least absent
mothers often without explanation
leaving us to presume them to be dead
now to be fair there's actually there's
a lot of just flat-out orphan characters
leaving a lot of Disney movies which
means you know no mother or father but
there's a fair number of characters who
have a father present but no mother you
know you've got Ariel
you've got jasmine you've got Belle
you've got Bambi so you've got all these
characters who have a father but no
mother in addition to all the ones who
just have no parents at all so what does
Disney have against mothers nothing even
when you factor in how many you know
evil stepmother figures there are which
actually is not as many as you would
think at the first place but it's not a
campaign against mothers it's actually
in a kind of awkward way a praising of
mothers because the reason that mothers
are absent from so many of these stories
is not because Disney or any storyteller
honestly but Disney's just sort of the
the Disney animated films just where
I've seen it pointed out
the most they're not trying to say you
know mothers aren't good or we don't
need them it's not anything like that
I've seen people twisted into you know
the sort of what does Disney have
against mothers nothing Disney in a
basically kind of reverse psychology way
is saying how important mothers are
because really think about why they
aren't there the thing is is that
mothers especially and like I said this
happens less in the more recent movies
but especially in films from you know 20
years ago plus mothers were seen as the
stabilizing force within a family so no
mother
is immediate shorthand for this family
dynamic is broken because and actually
if anything it's often an indictment of
the fathers I mean look at some of the
father figures I mentioned going all the
way back to somebody like Bambi you have
this absentee not particularly emotional
very stern father figure the Disney
Renaissance words that seem to really
happen a lot you've got characters like
Triton who just doesn't really get his
daughter at all
you've got Maurice who's you know a nice
enough guy but is obviously not quite
all there and he's he can barely sort of
keep himself together
you've got the Sultan who is just a
bumbling fool and even in in stories
where the mothers are present but like
barely getting any emphasis something
like Sleeping Beauty you've got these
father's just being all this over the
top and and causing all these problems
because the mothers are seen as the
stabilizing centering force so by
minimizing them it is a quick and easy
way to explain without having to devote
a ton of screen time to it why this
family dynamic has problems and
obviously you remove both parents that's
even easier of course this this hero or
heroine
as some sort of you know issues in terms
of trust stability home life what have
you they have no parents but even if you
just remove if you're gonna remove one
and say that it's a destabilizing force
you're gonna remove the mother there's
very it's very rare in these animated
films that you end up with a single
mother because the societal cliche
expectation is that oh a woman can
handle that and that is me talking about
societal baggage societal stereotype the
stereotypes which are of course not
representative reality there's plenty of
fathers who are perfectly capable of
taking care of their kids there are
plenty of mothers who are in over their
heads it goes it runs the gamut there
are plenty of orphans who are perfectly
well-adjusted but in terms of our
cultural laws Moses in our cultural
understanding the baseline shorthand of
these stories is orphan really messed up
single father we're kind of on shaky
ground single mother you're probably
doing okay both parents fine kids fine
so anytime and that's not to say that
you can't have you know a character on a
journey of personal growth with some
damage with some issues going on evil
with too stable parents but you have to
really dig in and devote time to
explaining what that issue is and why
the parents can't help and if you're
making a film especially a film for kids
which tend to favor shorter run times
ninety minutes or even less sometimes
then you don't want to sink five seven
ten minutes into having to explain why
the problem the hero is having is
something that the parents can't help
with when you can just save a craft out
of time by removing one or both the
parents and like I said if you got to
remove just one remove the mother people
can people click much easier on the idea
of father being in over his head trying
to raise his kids for some reason we're
still fixated on the mister
mom thing and as outdated of thinking as
that is sometimes the pop culture
understanding of something takes a long
friggin time to catch up to the reality
that we all know when we stop and think
about it for more than a few seconds so
the the lack of mothers in Disney films
it's not an agenda it's not any
statement well it's not any intentional
negative statement on mothers or that
mothers aren't necessary if anything
it's frequently pointing out how much of
a hole is left when they are there and
how home how often fathers are in over
their heads so it's if you're gonna say
it's a condemnation of anything it's a
condemnation of fathers and actually I
remember I don't know if it's still the
case now cuz I I don't I don't watch as
much TV as I used to but I remember
we're in the early 2000s ish that it
really seemed to be a spate of
incredibly stupid fathers on television
I don't know what was up with that I
don't have any where I'm going with that
I'm just remembering that all of a
sudden I don't know if that's still a
thing but in any case I've been meaning
to give my thoughts out on there as to
why Disney tends to not have mothers and
their films it's because mothers are
important so happy Mother's Day whatever
your thoughts are on this or if you just
want to say why your mother is
particularly awesome drop something down
in the comments let's talk about it
there's all the stuff to do such as
support me on patreon like subscribe
deck Dedic then it did that leaks for
all that and more is down in the
description so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]